bonsoir
alors je suis l'organisateur de 7 et 10
ans et je viens d'obtenir ma licence de
physique alors comprendre le monde
oui c'est le thème que j'ai donné cette
conférence alors moi je suis physicien
donc je vais vous expliquer comment moi
je comprends le monde ou du moins
j'essaye de le comprendre à laurent
physique c'est très simple il ya deux
théories pour ça la première la physique
quantique la physique quantique explique
les petits trucs alors ici
la discontinuité des échanges d'énergie
à l'échelle microscopique est décrite
par la mildt onion du système ici noté à
chapeau et les valeurs propres de 7
hamiltonien donne les énergies que
peuvent prendre ce système est
l'équation de schrödinger ici présentes
donne l'évolution de la mildt onians
appliqué à la fonction d'onde ça c'est
pour les petits trucs maintenant pour
les gros trucs l'équation d'einstein la
relativité générale en 1905
albert einstein nous a montré que la
lumière a vu une vitesse constante dans
tous les référentiels ce qui nous ouvre
la porte au voyage dans le temps
seulement dans le futur et on peut
décrire avec ça par exemple le système
solaire en introduisant une sonde espace
temps en l'espace temps c'est un
magnifique hall de host of différentiel
à quatre dimensions ou un tenseur
métriques est appliqué ce qui résout les
équations d'einstein et donnent
naissance à des géodésique et les objets
qui nous suit bissau
victor qu'est ce que tu fais là c'est
n'importe quoi
on essaie de crasse complètement
ridicule me suis fixé c'est pas que des
équations t'as vu ça où tu crois
vraiment qu'il va donner goût séance
avec tetro est là c'est pas ça tu vas
faire partir tout le monde et puis la
libération scientifiques ces phases-là
pétiet devant le public c'est pas ça
c'est un vrai boulot c'est un métier et
puis il faut du recul une maturité et
qu'on n'a pas enfin dix ans laisse la
place à des personnes qui rend
l'expérience
ouais oui la raison jan figel il a
raison je suis pas assez mature
heureusement que j'ai fait appel à
d'autres personnes comme pour me
supplient de des gens le plus sérieux
que moi j'ai fait appel à des
scientifiques des voyageurs des sportifs
des littéraires qui ont chacun une façon
d'appréhender le monde et de le
comprendre car c'est indispensable
aujourd'hui de comprendre le monde dans
lequel on vit
un monde qui bouge sans cesse de plus en
plus vite vous a fait la démarche de
venir assister à ce tedx et ça c'est top
bon voyage